Scientists have invented a machine that can
detect emotions even if someone’s expression
doesn’t change.
Can you read what I’m feeling?
Hey everyone, Amy here for DNews.
Part of what makes us human is that we experience
emotions.
But it’s still really hard to know what
other people are feeling, especially when
they’re trying to hide it.
So, what if machines could read and interpret
people’s emotions for us?
Well, scientists at MIT have thought of that,
and have developed a device that can detect
how you’re feeling without even looking
at your face.
See, we display emotions not just through
facial expressions and body language, but
with our entire physiology, things like our
heart rate, breathing, blood pressure, and
sweat.
These are the exact changes that lie detectors
look for when you’re hooked up to a polygraph.
But polygraphs require being physically plugged
in, which is an awfully cumbersome way to
get a read on someone’s mental state.
That’s where MIT’s device, dubbed “EQ-Radio”,
comes in.
It works by bouncing radio waves off a person
and analyzing how those waves are affected
by the rising and falling of their chest or
the vibrations of the pulse under their skin.
With this information, it can measure the
time between heartbeats and breaths, and notice
when they’re speeding up or slowing down.
The device then uses an algorithm to determine
how the data matches up with different emotional
states.
Researchers trained to recognize the emotions
of joy, pleasure, sadness and anger in 12
subjects, and it was able to identify these
emotions correctly 87% of the time.
And when it was shown a new subject, it could
guess how they were feeling more than 73%
of the time.
The scientists think this technology could
be used for things like market research, like
telling a production company what you’re
feeling when you watch their movie.
It could also help monitor people’s emotional
states for medical reasons, such as observing
people with depression.
But let’s not forget about facial expressions,
because the technology for reading faces is
also getting better.
5 years ago, Google’s algorithms could pick
out faces less than 16% of the time, which
isn’t very impressive.
Now software is so good at seeing and identifying
faces, apps on your phone can automatically
swap them.
Computers can measure the details of your
face remarkably well, and by analyzing the
relationship of certain points on your face,
they can guess how you feel with surprising
accuracy.
According to a 2014 study published in the
Proceedings of the National Academy of Sciences,
researchers at The Ohio State University created
a program that could identify not just the
six basic emotions of happiness, sadness,
fear, anger, surprise, and disgust, but a
total of 21 complex emotions, things like
“happy surprise” or “angry fear”.
They took 5,000 photographs of 230 volunteers
reacting to different scenarios.
After pinpointing a variety of facial muscles
that are used to express emotion, the software
was able to identify basic emotions 97% of
the time and complex emotions almost 77% of
the time.
This could help us diagnose and understand
people with autism, who have trouble expressing
emotions, or people with post-traumatic stress
disorder, and it may even allow us to learn
what’s happening in their brains when they
feel complex emotions.
So, computers that know how you feel might
just improve medical science, even if it is
a little creepy.
Oh no, now they know I’m uncomfortable and
it’s just making me more uncomfortable...
These algorithms that read your emotions wouldn’t
be possible without machine learning, the
first step towards Artificial Intelligence.
To learn why you shouldn’t panic about HAL
9000 just yet, check out Trace’s video on
AI here.
Do you see emotion recognition as a useful
tool or does it give you the heebee jeebees?
Let us know in the comments below.
Be sure to like this video and subscribe to
you never miss an episode of DNews.